all right so I just finished my round
four game in the carguro chess
tournaments
um as usual I'm a little bit rushed
because dinner closes in 26 minutes from
now it's 7 34 uh p.m so let me uh let me
just show the game uh I'm still trying
to process what happened I was playing
Grand Master kaido culottes not sure how
to pronounce his last name but
um yeah strong GM I mean every GM is uh
is pretty strong at chess uh rated 25-25
fide and I decided to go into an
accelerated Dragon uh we went into open
Sicilian and I played G6 and he opted
for the Marazzi bind with C4
and I was prepared for this actually
looked at this briefly before the game
Knight F6 Knight C3 D6
um there's different move orders here
but we got uh of a standard sequence of
moves Castle Queen D2 and here I go for
the plan A5 and the idea of this move is
to play a four and then eventually Queen
A5 and try and gain a bit of space on
the queen side
and here he played the move B3
which is already out of my preparation
it's one of the downsides actually of
playing and opening that I don't have
like so much experience in but I've been
dabbling with this a little bit and I
knew that there there's a move here to
play A4 he actually told me after the
game that there was a Carlton Carlson
game and clearly he wasn't lying as we
see it in the Masters database here uh I
think that game went A4 yeah A4 B4 is um
is one approach for black
um leads to a playable position I took
some time here uh let me hide notation
as usual later on I I'll probably just
check briefly with engine afterwards to
see uh See all the cool things that were
missed
um but okay in this position I played
Bishop to D7 uh going for just a more
kind of patient setup after Bishop E2
put the bishop on C6 I played 19 seven
Knight C5 I play E6 here
and so far we're kind of both staying
within our own territories I was
familiar with the setup uh this is a
line I've studied uh maybe about five or
six years ago and the idea of E6 is a
bit multi-purpose uh later there's ideas
of playing D5 but there's another idea
of playing Bishop E5 Queen H4 and trying
to orchestrate some King side attack uh
maybe also F5 to bust things open on the
king side so I was uh still kind of
within my comfort zone and here he plays
Bishop F1 I play Bishop B5 and then he
took a very long think and uh played
Knight to B5 if we see the time stamps
here yeah he took over half hour to play
this move and when he was thinking I
wasn't actually sure what to expect
because it's not the easiest position
for whites
um if white ever plays F4 then I very
simply taken when the E4 pawn and
meanwhile uh G3 looks a little bit
weakening
so Knight B5 there is some logic to it
he's trying to pressure D6 trying to
maybe maneuver to D4
um I went ahead and played B6 one point
of this move not only am I reinforcing
the knights but in the event of Knight
D4 I can keep the bishop on the long
diagonal
um and at some point I was dreaming and
playing F5 to make the bishop a bit
happier also make the Rook happier
so from here Rook D1 was played like
Queen H4 uh threatening H2 he plays G3
uh I go back to E7 and it looks like the
pawn is hanging because there's three
attackers but it's not really capturable
because rook d8 and then uh yeah the
knights just are gone you're here
so he plays Bishop G2 I play Rook d8
Knight C3 and then I play H5 and I was
feeling pretty good like it seemed like
he just uh didn't know what to do move
the Knight back and forth so lost a
couple Tempe but it's still very much of
a fight and then from here things very
quickly got really crazy plays Bishop G5
play F6 uh winning Connect Four but
unfortunately not quite winning the game
just yet uh he plays Bishop E3 back and
it looks weird because my Bishop is just
in front of my pawns it seems like it
might get trapped but I always have this
idea Bishop takes C3 if necessary so I
play H4 and then he plays Knight E2 and
now he's actually threatening to play F4
to trap the bishop so I go ahead and
play D5 and this is where things just
kind of explode in the center
of course The Rook is aligned with the
queen and he found a nice continuation
which I did anticipate in the game he
takes takes and plays Queen C2 attacking
the undefended g-pawn and this was one
of the downsides playing F6 is it kind
of weakened the squares around The King
and I had to spend a move to defend
played F5 and then he plays Bishop H6 I
was expecting Knight F4 uh I was
actually a bit more scared of this move
because it hits G6 and G5 but I think
maybe one reason he played Bishop H6 was
to remove the Bishop from being a Target
on E3
so I went ahead and played Rook F7 he
takes
and then I made an intuitive decision
here after the game he was saying that
maybe I should take on D5 uh maybe with
or Bishop but I decided to play the move
Bishop to B5
and when I first considered this move I
thought it was actually pretty strong
because I'm threatening to take on E2
and then play Bishop D4 in some cases
win the queen or when when some amount
of material there's other cases where if
he defends a knight then I have Bishop
D3 he's skewering the queen and Rook so
I thought this was a nice tactical move
even though I'm now down a pawn it feels
like there's some compensation
uh so he plays Knight D4 very logical
and then here I play Rook H7
counter-attacking uh I spent some time
on this move actually spent most of my
remaining time on this move I really
wanted to take take and then play G5
with the thread of Queen F6 double
attack but also trapping the bishop and
this almost works but white has to move
Queen D2 here uh defending the rook and
hitting G5 and uh yeah I think the
bishop is is being saved and box
probably just worse here
so I went for Rook H7 and then he took I
took he played F4 and I don't entirely
know
what my downfall was but he he got a lot
of initiative and like every move it
felt like I was getting punched in the
face uh and I just didn't really know
what to do like White's pieces are fully
optimized my Rook on H6 isn't actually
doing anything it's just staring into
empty space and I'm just down the pawn
uh this D5 Pawn is really strong after
Queen C4 I tried to muddy the waters
with 94 uh hitting G3 and the event of
takes takes and the queen could come in
but he played very nicely here he just
plays Queen C6 offering the queen trade
I didn't want to trade Queens but then
his Queen invaded and then he took the
knights and then plays Knight to D6
threatening the triple fork and uh yeah
things just went downhill from here I
gave a check uh covered F7 but then he
challenges H file and now it's white
actually attacking along the H file he's
ready to take and then play Rook H1
I tried to fight on but uh yeah it
didn't really pan out to anything
eventually he got a position where white
is up three pawns and I have no counter
play play it on a little bit longer
dreaming of the stalemate trap but after
95 I resigned here given 96 is coming
and yeah
um
uh there is no hope here for black
so that was a game
um I've I really don't know what to make
of it but I've had fun playing it and
I'm really not too disappointed because
I don't know exactly where I went wrong
so let me spend like a minute or two
just checking some of the key moments
with the engine and then I gotta run to
dinner so let's go to this position
after Bishop H6 enable stockfish wow I
was much better I could play D4 here
I don't think I considered this move
that Bishop f8
King f8 and now D3 is a threat man
so I had some extreme sack
I play Rook F7 and then it's closer to
equal I should have taken on D5 although
Bishop B5 is not bad
um ah Rook H7 was
a mistake
and then yeah then I think he played
very smoothly from here in the time
scramble
although it's still interesting
okay I had to play G5 here I considered
G5 but it loses F5 looks a little bit
too risky
um if we go forward I miss anything
after 96 now this is losing
okay so I had some chances but uh it was
a fun game apologies for the briefness
of this recap but I hope you guys
enjoyed it and learned a thing or two
and I'll be back for more so stay tuned
and I'll see you guys in the next video